question the financial that was moving
along very nicely I wanna thank you for
being here and update you on the
progress we've made after a week of
extraordinary mobilization in our war
against the virus governor's mayor's the
businesses charities and citizens are
all working with urgency and speed
toward one common goal which is saving
American lives were in communication
with foreign countries it's now at 148
foreign countries can you believe that
100 you talk about a spread you talk
about a violent spread 148 countries not
even believable there's been a week of
national action and of great national
solidarity people are getting along
we're getting along with Republicans and
Democrats and independents and liberals
and conservatives and actually it's a
very nice thing to say we're all one
beautiful big American family and that's
taking place right now
last night I approved a major disaster
declaration for the state of New York I
worked very closely with Governor Cuomo
and is the first time in our nation's
history that a presidents used the
Stafford Act to declare a major disaster
in response to a public health crisis
never happened before and considering
other areas where we may or may not be
doing it and working very closely with
Gavin Newsom governor of California
and others we may be doing the same
thing depending on their needs depending
on what they are asking for it's been
unprecedented action in New York and
we've had a tremendous federal response
all over the country and I want to thank
all the people in the federal government
and obviously in the state governments
and local governments we are working
hard everybody is working hard and the
people standing alongside of me are
working very hard that I can tell you
we've also reached agreements with
Canada and Mexico on new travel rules at
our northern and southern borders to
halt the entry of the Chinese virus well
continuing trade and commerce and we've
had very good talks I've with Prime
Minister Trudeau and today this morning
with President Lopez Obrador we talked
about joint measures that were taken to
prevent the spread of the virus in our
countries and to temporarily suspend
non-essential travel we had a great
conversation this morning president of
Mexico and our close cooperation with
Mexico and Canada will keep our people
healthy keep their people healthy keep
everybody safe
yesterday I had a call with 12,000 small
businesses representatives of these
businesses that's the engine of our
country people don't realize that you
know you read all about the big ones but
these small business when you add them
up together is a really the engine
economic engine of our country and I
assured them that my administration is
doing everything within it's very
considerable considerable power frankly
to support them and their employees
nobody's ever done what we've done
likewise I had calls during the week
with all sorts of representatives and
systems like the hospital system we
spoke to many of the hospital systems
throughout the country nurses and
doctors representatives representing
hundreds of thousands of nurses and
doctors airlines and cruise ship
companies the Business Roundtable which
was fully attended and it's all of the
top CEOs of of our country and beyond
frankly the businessmen of really these
are world a world style businessman
these are a businessman that control the
biggest companies in the world many of
them have taken hits and many of them
are just you know going forward that
they've got their businesses have been
have been great some have been very
badly affected some of it affected at
all and frankly some
or doing very well they continue to do
very well it's Walmart as an example has
been really helpful to us Doug McMillon
head of Walmart really helpful to us and
I guess I assume they're doing pretty
well because people is certainly buying
by more and more than even a clip at
Christmas by substantial numbers pretty
amazing but they're doing incredibly
they put on tremendous extra staff you
don't have empty shelves a lot of things
have happened that are very good
restaurants fast food executives grocery
stores all retailers literally all of
them in groups and we spoke with the g7
leaders at length as you know you
probably know about that spoke to many
of the governors spoke to almost all of
the governor's at conference calls and
many of the governor's individually and
very importantly the religious leaders
we had a great conversation yesterday
the vice president and myself with the
religious leaders of of our country many
of the religious leaders and we've had a
number of them during the course of the
last two weeks actually but yesterday we
had a very very significant call with
the religious leaders of our country
I signed legislation providing American
workers with paid sick leave and paid
family medical leave at no cost to
employers and free testing for those who
need it the testings going very well and
the Admiral will speak to that along
with Tony we're working quickly to pass
additional legislation that will provide
massive relief to small businesses and
affected industries and give direct
payments to our great workers and
hard-working American families has never
been anything like we're doing on the
hill right now they're negotiating Mitch
McConnell Chuck Schumer the roll up
there Kevin McCarthy and Nancy Pelosi
they're all negotiating and everybody's
working hard and they want to get to a a
solution that's the right solution I
think we're getting very close
we've also announced that we've moved
tax day from April 15th to July 15th
which is a big deal giving businesses
and individuals extra time to file and
pay without interest or penalties so we
move the date way back and so it'll be
July 15th instead of your traditional
April 15th and very importantly you will
have a lot of time but you're not going
to have interest penalties or any kind
of penalties by filing at that later
date HUD announced that foreclosures and
evictions are suspended for
single-family home owners with FHA
insured mortgages for the next 60 days
and our great head of HUD who's with us
today Ben Carson's going to say a few
words in a moment the Department of
Education will not enforce standardized
testing which is another big deal
requirements for students in elementary
through high school for the current
school year not fair to do that so we we
are waiving that I'm I would imagine
it's probably the first time ever that's
been waived but I think it's only fair
to the students and to the parents of
the students it is also waiving interest
and other things that we're discussing
right now on federally held student
loans and directed that borrowers be
allowed to suspend their student loan
payments without penalty for at least 60
days and we'll be talking about student
loans to help the students they're under
a great burden right now so we will be
talking about that further but we're
we're waving during this 60-day period
various elements and very important
elements on student loans big subject I
signed an executive order invoking the
defense production act as you all know
giving us powerful new authorities to
help state cities and hospitals for cure
needed supplies there's been a clear
call to action to the private sector and
the call is made right here it's been
really pretty amazing what's happened
with the private sector they are really
in sixth gear I think which is responded
in full force helping to produce and
supply much needed masks swabs
sanitizers ventilators and everything
else is is a move on that's incredible
right now and by way of example Haines
everybody knows Haines great company
great consumer cotton products company
is retrofitting its manufacturing
capabilities in large sections of their
plants to produce masks and they're in
that process right now then in my
direction the FDA has taken rapid steps
to make these items available for
medical use right now I mean most
excitingly to me is what the FDA has
done in order to get possibly a very
successful number it's not just one or
two number of therapeutics medicines
that can help help people that are
already sick help people not get sick
then obviously you know about the
vaccine and Tony will discuss that a
little bit later but the vaccine is
moving along but this is something that
right now for right now if this is what
we really it's incredible and what the
FDA has done and dr. Steven Hahn was
highly respected came as a just a highly
respected man he's been fantastic he's
only been here for a couple of months
and he's he's gotten thrown into the
swim of it and he's really standing up
but the FDA has really moved mountains I
said it this morning they moved
mountains to get approvals on things
that that may be work we'll find out
very soon and we'll take along an
example of the pair no Ricard which is
this is really an example where we're
repurposing alcohol they went out and
repurposed their alcohol production
capabilities in Arkansas Kentucky Texas
and West Virginia to make hand sanitizer
that's a big difference and they've been
unbelievable they really pernod ricard
their first delivery will be on Tuesday
it's going to go to various states
they're gonna start I think in New York
and they're gonna work their way around
they're making a tremendous amount of
hand sanitizer at a very high level too
by the way
we've activated the National Response
Coordination Center to level one that's
your highest level
there's the nerve center of all of our
government response to crisis and it's
coordinating very closely with our
nation's governor's our nation's
governor's many of you were at the call
yesterday with the governors and I think
you can see the relationship and we've
had numerous calls with governor's by
the way but the relationships are pretty
amazing they they're like they're loving
what we're doing and the the
coordination between the federal
government and the governors states and
even local has been pretty incredible
FEMA administrator Pete Gaynor who is
with us will soon be providing you with
an update on the center's operations and
FEMA's been incredible we got them
involved last week for a much involved
another involved nationwide we've
dramatically expanded telehealth so
Americans can see a doctor without
leaving home something which more and
more people are using and now they're
really using it and now the ones that
are using it are loving it and I think
we're gonna change the way our country
functions medically and probably in
other ways because of what's going on
right now this will reduce the chance of
infection and preserve hospital capacity
so it sells a lot of problems every
American is a role to play in defending
our nation from this invisible horrible
enemy it really is it's an invisible
enemy and we will be successful very
successful hopefully very much sooner
than people would even think so we say
stay at home and save lives there's a
time of shared national sacrifice but
it's also a time to treasure our loved
ones and to take stock of what is most
important our faith our families our
neighbors in our great country and I
want to thank all of the incredible
people of our country this
distance of our country that what you've
done and the way you're responding has
just been very special something that we
will never forget that the history books
will never forget then we're gonna have
a great victory we're gonna be
celebrating a great victory in the
not-too-distant future and I just want
to thank everybody and now uh I'll
introduce our vice president Mike
Pence's led the task force and I will
tell you this he has not slept much
maybe a tiny bit maybe a little bit but
not much
and he's done an incredible job Mike
thank you please good afternoon all and
Thank You mr. president the White House
coronavirus task force met today we
briefed the President on our latest
recommendations we continue at the
president's direction and to lead not a
whole-of-government approach but a whole
of America approach you just heard the
president describe one inspiring story
after another at the way the American
people are responding the way American
businesses are responding religious
communities across this country the
American people are coming together
they're responding with common sense
compassion and generosity people are
heeding the advice of state and local
authorities and tens of millions of
Americans are putting into practice 15
days to slow the spread we are we are
officially mr. president it's six days
into our 15 days and as we look all
across this country while we we strongly
support the decisions that governors in
states where we have significant
outbreak have taken we encourage every
American to listen to those state and
local authorities for every American
this is what you can do to make a
difference over the next week and a few
days to protect your health protect your
families
but most especially slow the spread and
the potential for the coronavirus to
impact the most vulnerable as the
president said we we've been we've
almost been overwhelmed at the
outpouring of support from American
businesses the president spoke yesterday
to thousands of small businesses we
spoke to manufacturers yesterday and in
fact as the president indicated the FDA
in in record time just approved one
manufacturer that will be producing
millions of surgical masks in a matter
of weeks for the American people the
pastors we spoke to we we want to thank
all the religious leaders from every
community of faith in the country making
a hard choice to suspend services to
have online services even while those
ministries are continuing to support
food banks and come alongside of the
most vulnerable and of course the chorus
of prayers that is coming up from
communities of faith around the country
is making the difference that it always
has in the life of this nation one thing
the president and I promised was to
remind people that on the the weekends
that you're not in the pews it's still
the good it's still a good idea to if
you can to go ahead and make that
donation continue because all the
ministries are continuing to play a
vital role in our communities and we
encourage your continued support the
President and I are grateful that the
American people are listening to state
and local authorities and and putting
into practice all of all of the
recommendations in the president's
coronavirus guidelines and as you will
hear in just a few moments from Admiral
Gua testing is expanding rapidly across
the United States of America state-run
drive-throughs are expanding across the
country and as you will hear detailed
this morning now more than a hundred and
ninety five thousand Americans and more
who have been symptomatic have been
tested that number does not include
County hospitals or or healthcare labs
around the nation some 15,000 in
number and among the number of the more
than a hundred and ninety-five thousand
that have been tested it's important to
remember that only nineteen thousand
three hundred and forty three at this
moment have tested positive for the
corona virus we want to we continue to
urge state and local health authorities
to contact FEMA for all the latest
developments and innovations in testing
but we want to remind Americans as dr.
Fauci will emphasize in a moment if you
don't have symptoms don't do a test it
is another way that the American people
can make sure that we are preserving the
resources that our health care workers
need to minister and to support those
who are dealing with the corona virus
and other illnesses in a moment
Pete Gaynor will detail the efforts at
FEMA since the president's national
emergency declaration we have FEMA in
the lead stood up the National Response
Coordination Center as the president
said and we are working closely
literally hour by hour through FEMA
processing requests from states most
impacted like New York Washington State
and California and will continue and to
work very very closely with those states
through the very traditional means of
federal emergency management at FEMA
secretary Carson will describe decisive
actions the president alluded to to
bring foreclosure relief to Americans
and on the subject of supplies in a
moment you will hear of not only the
progress that we're making on testing
but on Monday we'll be detailing for the
American people the progress that we are
making on the president's strategy of
procuring more personal protective
equipment and medical supplies
allocating them through the system of
FEMA and continuing to urge the
conservation by Americans in fact I'm
pleased to report to the president today
that HHS just placed an order for
hundreds of millions of n95 masks that
will be being made available to
healthcare providers across the country
on behalf of the president we do renew
our call for Americans to postpone elect
medical procedures including dental
services and remember this is another
way that you're going to make sure that
medical supplies are available because
by postponing elective medical
procedures you're freeing up medical
supplies for those dealing with the
coronavirus as the president mentioned
our team is on Capitol Hill as we speak
working with members of Congress in both
political parties they're making
progress
by all accounts on a bipartisan bill
they worked late into the night last
night started early this morning and we
are working to pass that legislation on
Monday in both the House and the Senate
now on a personal note many of you may
have been made aware that a member of my
staff has tested positive for the corona
virus we learned of that late yesterday
I am pleased to report that he's doing
well
he had mild cold like symptoms for about
a day and a half has not been to the
White House since Monday neither the
president nor I had direct contact with
that staff person
we worked immediately with a White House
physician and the CDC we've done all
contact tracing and while the White
House doctor has indicated that he has
no reason to believe that I was exposed
and no need to be tested given the
unique position that I have as vice
president and as the leader of the White
House coronavirus task force both I and
my wife will be tested for the corona
virus later this afternoon let me say
again how grateful the President and I
are that every American has acted on the
president's coronavirus guidelines we
are six days into 15 days that as dr.
Fauci may well reflect in a moment is an
opportunity for us here on the foot
holes of this epidemic curve in our
country to literally lower the impact in
our nation and save lives every American
can do their part to slow the spread and
we encourage you to continue to do that
as the president says often remember
we're all in this together and also
remember that that for for most
Americans their risk of serious illness
from the
Rhona virus remains low the reason we
want to put into practice the
president's coronavirus guidelines is
because no america would want to
inadvertently expose someone who is
vulnerable a senior with a serious
underlying health condition to the
corona virus with the potential threat I
did hear one story this morning mr.
president about a senior named Jennifer
wood she actually is at the life care
center in Kirkland Washington she is not
only a grandmother she is a great-great
grandmother
90 years young and she tested positive
for the corona virus on March 6 but by
all accounts she's doing well and she
wanted America to know there is hope and
her strength in her enthusiasm it's
truly an inspiration to the nation as
the president said many times we're
gonna get through this and come out
stronger than ever before and we'll get
through this as Americans together Thank
You mr. president very much thank you
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president as I told you earlier last
week we are in the process and are
effectively transitioning to large-scale
testing by leveraging all the components
of the American health healthcare system
when we started it with CDC only then it
was the state public health laboratories
now we're transitioning into the
mainstream of American testing with many
of the companies that the president
invited in the Rose Garden just a week
ago so currently 91 public health
laboratories state public health
laboratories are up and running in 50
states the District of Columbia Guam and
Puerto Rico this is our curve and I want
to be very clear about this that this
only accounts for CDC state public
health laboratories and the laboratories
that are members of the American
Clinical Laboratory Association these
are the main reference laboratories
LabCorp Quest Mayo Europe bio reference
labs ensoniq health care it does not
account for the well over 10,000 15,000
hospital based labs many of which
are doing testing for whom we will get
data this week to give you an overall
roll off as you can see over a hundred
ninety five thousand people in America
have completed their testing that means
tests plus results this does not count
the people whose tests are in process
and as you see this curve is going it
will continue to rise dramatically over
the next period of time so again this is
utilizing all the components of the
great American healthcare system the
state and local public health
laboratories the hospital system which
is not represented here in the main
reference laboratories now I do want to
make it clear that although testing is
becoming more available and doctor foul
Qi will definitely emphasize this more
there are priorities for testing and
clearly everyone across the country
should understand that those
hospitalized are in an ICU or a priority
for testing symptomatic healthcare
workers for obvious reasons we want to
make sure that they their health is
preserved and that they are not going to
spread to those who may be seriously ill
symptomatic people in long-term care
facilities as the Vice President is
highlighted and we've said many times
elderly in our society have a much
higher mortality rate much higher
serious complication rate symptomatic
individuals over 65 symptomatic
individuals who have underlying
conditions like chronic heart disease or
liver disease or other types of chronic
diseases patients and public health
investigations and there are local
priorities around the country
particularly health care workers for
testing and doctor foul she's gonna
emphasize this about the types of people
who may not be to be tested testing is
going well it's ramping up but we should
still have priorities finally I want to
talk about the community-based testing
sites I know they're popular now because
you know there's now an acronym which
I'm sure the vice-president doesn't
appreciate CBTs or CBT sites we talked
about these earlier in the week and I
wanted to emphasize again that these are
state managed and locally executed the
federal government is there to provide
port know-how blueprint blueprints on
how to do this but these are really
springing up at dozens and dozens of
sites all over the country adapt it to
the local needs some are drive through
the summer walk up some are geared to
health care workers and emergency
responders so again what we see in the
upcoming week is this curve will
continue to increase as testing becomes
more widely available as the great
American healthcare industry continues
to increase the availability of tests
and the throughput of those tests thank
you very much mr. president mr. vice
president what I want to do just over
the next minute or so is maybe connect
some of the dots of the things that
you've heard today first the status of
the dynamics of the of the outbreak I
mean you all know the numbers you've
seen them we have widespread infection
but to varying degrees throughout the
country so for example when you talk
about the kinds of mitigation issues
that we have put forth and have
emphasized just as I mentioned the other
day there are two dynamic forces that
are going on at the same time you're
having the natural course of an outbreak
trying to peak at a high level and then
you have the mitigation strategies which
are aimed at dampening that we've
mentioned that multiple times we often
get asked how do you know you're having
an effect because there are two things
that are going on at the same time they
may be confounding well I can tell you
for sure from a public health standpoint
and experience with other outbreaks we
know we are clearly having an effect but
we can't quantitate it for you
accurately now because looking forward
you'll know what the impact of the rate
of this steep inclines will be so that's
why we're gonna come back to you every
day and keep you up-to-date about that
getting with regard to the
disproportionate of the response
everyone is right here I'll get to open
up the vice president's book what is
permission
this is baseline for everyone
in other words throughout the country
but then there will be areas and you've
heard them Washington state California
New York City in which the the the
dynamic
of the outbreak are clearly different
and much more robust if you want to use
that word and that's the reason why
we've seen the mitigation ratcheted up
in that regard and again hopefully and I
have confidence it will happen you will
see an impact on that next getting to
testing you saw the numbers with testing
remember there was always an issue with
testing I think we're getting to the
solution that everybody in the country
is looking for but I want to emphasize
one thing that Admiral Jawa mentioned is
that not every single person in the
United States needs to get tested he
gave you the priorities I don't want to
repeat them but let me tell you one of
the unintended consequences of
individuals who don't need to get tested
that flood the desire to get tested
currently and I hope you'll be able to
change it and make it much less reliable
on PPEs when you go in and get tested
you are consuming personal protective
equipment masks and gowns those are high
priority for the healthcare workers who
were taking pair of people who have
cooked a corona virus disease so what we
don't want to do is to have a situation
where we will we do have disparities and
availability of PPE s now and we're
working hard to correct that but
currently today we want to make sure
that the people who are taking care of
people with coronavirus disease do not
endanger themselves because they don't
have the personal protective equipment
and then finally one last thing was just
mentioned the Surgeon General has been
pushing this please put off canceled
elective medical and surgical procedures
you don't want to not ever do them but
for the time being don't do them because
they also not only consume personal
protective equipment they may also
consume some of the things like
ventilate is that you might need so
let's pull in this together and we will
get through it I promise you thank you
[Music]
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president FEMA is now leading the
federal operation all the federal
response for all operations on behalf of
the White House corner virus task force
who always sees this whole of nation
response HHS will continue to provide
their expert matter expertise on health
and pursuant to the nationwide emergency
declaration FEMA in coordination with
HHS is assisting state local tribal
territorial governments and their other
eligible entities with health and safety
emergency protective measures on behalf
of the American public as of yesterday
50 states the District of Columbia five
territories and one tribe are working
directly with FEMA under the nationwide
emergency declaration for kovin 19 in
just 24 hours we've obligated 100
million dollars through States
territories and tribes a little bit
about supplies it is of the utmost
importance that requests for assistance
especially for critical supplies get
routed through proper channels as soon
as possible
and we asked everyone to follow the
normal procedures the normal procedures
FEMA uses in a natural disaster there is
no different procedure for the Cova 19
and emic but remember you can still
order supplies from your regular vendors
and buy it on the open market
buy it where you can find it we will
reimburse you if you buy medical
supplies from foreign sources it is
reimbursable by America does not apply
to the Stafford Act except for
Washington DC and Puerto Rico if you
can't buy it on the open market make a
request through the FEMA system request
for assistance at the local and county
level should first go to States from
States to the regional FEMA offices and
then from those offices right here in DC
where the National Response Coordination
Center is open and running we are
getting requests for mass PPE swab sets
test site supports ventilators hospital
capacity assessments and many more we
are in lockstep with HHS to answer these
requests but what we will do whatever is
necessary to get States tribes
territories and others they what they
need and then finally what we are doing
here in Washington DC
again this is a whole-of-government
response like all emergencies response
is most successful when it is locally
executed state managed and fairly
supported we can't say that enough on
Thursday a federal partners fully
integrated with our National
Coordination Response Coordination
Center and additionally all 10 FEMA
regions across the country have been
activated the FEMA regional
administrators will continue to
coordinate closely with governor's state
of Mercy managers state public health
officials to determine the type and
level of support needed to respond to
this dynamic threat Thank You mr.
president and mr. vice president for
your tireless leadership here and I also
want to thank the fellow Task Force
members who have been working around the
clock on a very patriotic way to serve
their fellow Americans you know part of
the American Dream is having a home and
sometimes people say well what is
housing help do it health it has
everything to do with help having a safe
home and that is the reason that the
president has authorized the immediate
cessation of foreclosure and eviction
proceedings for American citizens single
family for work mortgages as well as
reverse mortgages and as you know FHFA
has also decided to do the same thing
for 60 days and the CFPB is very happy
with all this as well and it's really
all about helping our people recognizing
that they're being severely impacted by
the krona by virus and we've also asked
the various services of mortgage loans
to exercise forbearance for anybody
who's having difficulty it is important
if you're having difficulty to actually
contact the people who have made the law
who established the mortgage because it
doesn't happen automatically what does
happen automatically is that
we cover all eight point five million
people in terms of the moratorium on
foreclosures and evictions we want also
for the PHAs to be protected HUD does
not have authority to mandate that
evictions can occur but we are in
contact with all the PHAs across the
country and are petitioning Congress for
the power to be able to actually enforce
that but the fact of the matter is most
of the PHAs are run by people who
actually care about other people so we
really haven't seen much of a problem
there we haven't seen much of a problem
with forbearance and needing to try to
force people to do it because they want
to do it people are stepping up and
saying what can we do to be helpful as
far as Housing Choice Voucher section
eight is concerned that April vouchers
will be sent out next week and may
bouncers are already being worked on and
we're also staying in contact with all
the stakeholders the advocates for
low-income housing as well as other
stakeholders to make sure that we're
doing things that are most helpful to
them and additionally we've extended the
deadlines for healthcare and
multi-family financial reporting
requirements and that's for over 20,000
multifamily and health care borrowers
until April the 30th and that provides
them with a lot more flexibility to deal
with the issues that they're dealing
with I also want to thank our FHA
commissioner Brian Montgomery as well as
the FHFA director mark Calabria and
Kathy cran enjoyed the director of the
CFPB who've all worked tirelessly with
us to make this happen what we're trying
to do is bridge the gap recognizing that
it's a lot easier for us to take these
measures and for Congress to take the
measures that they're taking so that we
destroy a very excellent system and have
to start all over again so for those who
are worried about the money that's being
spent if you don't spend the money and
deal with this now it's kind of cost a
whole lot more to try to build all this
up again and as was mentioned by the
president there's been a sense of unity
that we haven't seen for a long time
in this country and let's hope and pray
that that unity last far beyond this
crisis then thank you very much if
you've lost your job now or you're
worried that you're gonna lose your job
tomorrow of restaurant something like
that what do you want people to do
immediately the second point is deserve
you we've heard from the vice president
that he's going to be tested are you and
he taking a test this last Saturday okay
those people lost their job already or
they're worried that they're about to
lose it tomorrow
that's what do you want them to do right
now well what they do right now is keep
receiving their paycheck and hopefully
their companies are gonna be in a very
strong position we want to keep
everything together because we think
we're gonna have a tremendous
bounce-back now some people agree with
that very strongly
some of our top economists say think
we're gonna have a very once we solve
the problem of that we're working on the
medical problem so we want them to keep
their jobs stay where you are
and we'll see what happens now if they
don't we have unemployment we have
checks we have a lot of things happening
a lot of very positive things nobody has
ever done know this is working with
Democrats as Republicans and Democrats
and myself working together nobody's
ever done a package like this it's a
great package but ideally we want them
to be able to keep their jobs keep the
pay coming and I think that's gonna
happen Kelly go ahead mr. president on
your defense production Act power one of
the features of that is that the federal
government would be able to control the
output whether it's masks or ventilators
that get it to the most areas of need
and control the pricing to keep it at a
market level so it's not price gouging
one of the things we're hearing from
governors they can't find supplies and
prices have gone up so you've talked
about the actor but you have not yet
compelled any companies why not because
we have so many companies making so many
products every product that you
mentioned Plus ventilators and
everything else we have car companies
without having to use the act if I don't
have to use specifically we have the act
to use in case we need it but we have so
many things being made right now by so
many they've just stepped up in fact
Mike Pence and I were discussing it
before we've never seen anything like it
where they are volunteering we want to
make masks for Mike Haynes I've brought
that up as an example General Motors I
bring that up is another Ford it's so
right they're going they're going to go
in the open market we want them on the
open market from the standpoint of
pricing because otherwise you it's gonna
be we could be very unfair aggressive to
the places in greatest need we are
directing States and sometimes we'll be
competing against States which I don't
want and we'll drop out of the bidding
we want the states to go first and you
know what we're doing is we're helping
States that's what we want to do same
thing with the testing we're helping
States we're helping States get to where
they want and we've made tremendous
progress in every aspect of what happens
today well it's happening fast right now
and the governors are out there trying
to get and if they are competing with us
we immediately drop out please president
I forgive me if I heard you wrong
he said something we are going to be
going over to the hill are you going
yourself my people are and I'll be
staying here I'll be in the Oval Office
and various other places in the White
House that matter you're asking Congress
to essentially pass a series of
legislation that's going to amount to
about two trillion dollars ten percent
of the GDP what do you say to members in
both parties who say this is too
expensive this is just too much to
debate and get done in 48 hours or so
and also have you spoken directly with
Speaker Pelosi at all
okay so I've spoken with I'm not gonna
say who I speak with but I've spoken
with directly or indirectly everybody
many many times we're doing very well I
think the Democrats and the Republicans
are gonna come up with a package that's
going to be really something very
special it's going to help people this
is the first time there's ever been a
case where you want people not to work
it's always you know you want to create
an incentive to work we're creating not
an incentive not to work but the fact is
we're asking people not to work because
of we have to stay away from each other
if we're gonna kill this horrible hidden
enemy we have to stay away so there's
never been a thing like this in the
history of the world and the other
nations are doing similar things some
effectively some not effectively they're
doing similar things we are creating a
package that's going to keep companies
together keep workers paid so they can
live and sustain we'll see what the
timing is the biggest thing we can do is
get rid of the problem the problem is
exactly what we know the medical problem
we want to have this whole incredible
situation that it can start right away
not that all these companies break up
all the workers are out of jobs you
can't put them back together and it
would take years to put them back
together because we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world
until we got hit by this problem and we
can be back very very quickly and it's
in our intention to be back very very
quickly so we're doing a package the
likes of which nobody's ever done before
I'm obviously the one that has to
approve the different things and the
recommendations of the different things
and like by vechs as an example and
stock buybacks I didn't like it the
first time at this time I'm saying
you're not doing it I don't want money
to be used for that I want money to be
used for workers and for opening
businesses keeping businesses oh not
buybacks and well I would I am strongly
recommending a buyback exclusion you
cannot buy back your stock you can't
take a billion dollars of the money and
just buy back your stock and increase
the value please on the subject of mass
the vice president announced HHS was
ordering a hundreds of millions of them
was that ordered Jeff place today how is
that going to be distributed in one
conductors the nurses expect to actually
receive those mats yeah HHS is
completing a half a billion dollar or of
n95 masks and and all of this is being
coordinated through FEMA and and we're
we are responding specifically to state
and requests where the needs arrive as
dr. Fauci said we want to make sure the
people that are providing health care
services to people who may have
contracted coronavirus have the
protection to keep themselves and their
families healthy but I want to emphasize
the the supply of so-called n95 masks
has been vastly increased in the country
because the president insisted that we
extend liability protection to
industrial masks what all the experts
told us early on was that industrial
masks that are used on construction
sites the president's very familiar with
from his past life are perfectly
appropriate to protect healthcare
workers from respiratory illness but
they didn't have the liability
protection because they weren't created
for hospitals we worked in with leaders
in both parties we added that protection
that runs through 2024 that now the
industrial end ninety-five mass can be
purchased by hospitals purchased by
states purchased by HHS and distributed
through our systems so we're making
those available the supply has been as I
said vastly increased and it's it was
another step forward in a bipartisan
accomplishment and we're continuing to
use all the kind of creative means of
American
industry to make sure that we're leaning
into this effort and that that we do
whatever it takes to make sure that our
healthcare providers have the protective
equipment they'll hear from doctors and
nurses about the shortage when exactly
can they expect to receive these masks
though well let me let let me let Pete
Gaynor speak to that because FEMA will
be HHS is now fully integrated into FEMA
and so as the requests come in but
obviously as I'm sure the administrator
will say they're being prioritized to
those areas with the highest need us so
within the National Coordination Center
we have a supply chain task force in a
basic sense we're trying to identify the
universe of what's out there so whether
we hold it at the federal level we hold
it in the private sector and then match
that up with demand and asking people to
be creative we're asking again this is a
shared responsibility we're asking
locals and states to do your share
locally try to take a little bit burden
off of us and then we'll prioritize
those scarce resources because every
single governor across the country is
looking for the exact same thing so
there's a balance but we're examining
the entire supply chain to make sure
that we make masks start coming in
they're there they're out there now so
again we want to match we want to get
out of the middle I think
[Laughter]
so we're trying to match suppliers with
the man so that's what we're doing right
now
it's happening today it's they can they
can expect them to they're the matching
supply in Amman it is a there's a range
of requests across the country and we're
trying to match those again supply and
demand everyday what I've already come
in I have to tell you the they throwing
away of the mask being in private
business they're throwing away the mask
right away they're thrown away and when
you hear 55 million masks world I'm
saying 55 million how could it possibly
be such a number and they say oh that's
just a small fraction of what we need
and I said why are we sanitizing masks
you know you look at the mess I've
looked at all the different masks some
don't lead themselves to doing that I
think but many do and I said why aren't
we have very good liquids for doing this
sanitizing the masks and that's
something they're they're starting to do
more and more the sanitizing the masks
and I don't know if anybody would like
to speak to that CDC guidance is about
how you can minimize the use of masks by
different things that you could do with
testing and when you have masks how you
might reuse them which ones you can be
used them do you think there's a
solution to this other than buying more
mass you have to everybody need to
change how they're using them yeah well
there are a couple of things one for
example we are moving towards getting
testing where you don't have to have PPE
I mean I don't want it I'm not gonna
tell you the day he is gonna be there
but it's gonna be a swab that you could
stick in the nose of the person who is
either infected or not but that person
doesn't need PPE
the person who's administering the test
so if you could do a self administer
tests stick it in a vial hand it over
you don't need a mask you don't need PPE
that's one of the things we're trying to
do I would have liked that much better
may I and one other this is another
story about a great American industry we
the President and I literally heard
directly from Apple that they're
donating two million industrial masks to
this effort around the country and
working with our administration to
distribute those and it might be a good
opportunity for us to renew our call for
as the president and I delivered this
message to businesses yesterday
manufacturers and small businesses it's
a great time to go to your storeroom and
if you have in 95 masks if you've got a
hundred of them if you've got 10,000 of
them is to load them up drive them over
to your local hospital that story is
literally happening all over the country
and now with more Americans stepping
away from elective surgery including
elective dental care verging Denys
around America to look at their supplies
of n95 mess and make those available to
our hospitals and but the great news is
is the president said the American
people are all doing this now so allow
me to say on behalf of the president
thank you for you all are doing today
but we want to encourage people in
business encourage people in dentistry
in particular look at those supplies of
n95 max pack up as many as you can spare
drop them off at your local hospital be
a great service to the country I just
want to read you some of what some of
the doctors on the frontlines of this
crisis are saying that doctors are
saying good things or bad these are
doctors who are talking about the
shortage of medical supplies that they
are facing dr. Faisel bucks in Kentucky
says there's absolutely no way to
protect myself a surgeon in Fresno
California says we are at war
a mo dr. Mel in Illinois says if this is
a wartime situation then now is the time
to act I know you're talking now about
increasing production at so many of
these facilities to get the masks out
but given that this is one of the
wealthiest most powerful countries in
the world should this even be happening
shouldn't this have been resolved well
I'll tell you the way I look at it so
many administrations preceded me for the
most part they did very little in terms
of what you're talking about this is
unprecedented you could speak to Tony
you can speak to anybody this is
unprecedented or just about
unprecedented as time goes by we're
saying it's really at a level that
nobody would have believed nobody would
have thought possible that this could
happen and we are making much of this
stuff now and much of it's being
delivered now we've also gotten
tremendous reviews from a lot of people
they can't believe how fast it's coming
when when I hear they have an order of
55 million masks and that's just one
order that's one order out of many and
that there are many millions of masks
beyond that that and I keep saying how
is it possible to use so much but that's
the way it is and part of that is
because they they'll use a mask for a
short period of time and they throw it
the fact is that we are doing a
tremendous amount we started with very
few masks we had some but nothing for an
event like this and now we're making
tens of millions of masks and other
things and I think it's unprecedented
what we've done and what we're doing and
many doctors that I've read many many
doctors they can't believe the great job
that we've done yes Kelly did you have
has been more than this purely for
questions for administration learn about
this
this virus well if you remember I was
knowing that I was the one that closed
the country down I was the one that
closed the you know right that or you
don't say it too much certainly on CNN
but I just read an article yesterday I
just read an article yesterday that by
closing the country down so early so
very early we saved tens of thousands
and much more than that lives so you
know you might want to report that what
I just like to address that for a moment
again I'm an ICU physician ran health
systems and I first of all want to thank
everyone who's on the frontline in the
emergency room and the ICS and the
hospitals I speak to my colleagues daily
we need to preserve our PPE to the
degree that we can CDC guidelines has
had that the president has talked about
it but I also want to say we are making
product as the president said but we are
also responding through the FEMA system
to distribute the strategic national
stockpile resources according to
requests that come in stockpile has been
distributed to many states first order
second orders and on a daily basis
adjudicating that if there are shortages
in your hospital system I can't tell you
of dr. XYZ that needs to be clearly
iterated to the local emergency
management segoe with over two thousand
hospitals or hospital systems sharing
best practices from Seattle where
they've been very innovative pioneering
some of these areas when there is a
shortage they need to go through their
emergency management it goes directly up
to the FEMA system which really rocks
it really works very very well and then
there's a distribution of the stockpile
now the stockpile is an infinite that's
why it's being replaced by all the
orders but met masks supplies go out on
a daily basis as they are needed and
requested through the FEMA system and I
don't know administrator gain or whether
you want
just to reiterate what would Whitbread
said we don't take lightly
what you just read you know I mean I get
the calls every night the way you get
emails it's a serious issue we don't
want that to happen but it is happening
you're not making things up I I know
that because I'm experiencing myself but
what you just heard about the different
avenues some of which aren't even
recognized about how you can get help
through the FEMA process in addition to
the large amounts of additional PPE
that's coming into the system
we hope that very very very soon we're
not going to get those kinds of
real-life difficulties there's a
question about the timeline here and
even FEMA can't quite answer yeah sooner
than weeks it's it's it's gonna be days
I would hope you know I we're gonna try
to make it days to the best possible way
we can we're doing is we're trying to
help the states get things faster and
that's what we're doing we're
implementing and the magnitude of this
it's a tragedy it's an absolute tragedy
but the magnitude is something that no
matter who you were no matter where you
come from nobody ever thought a thing
like this could happen you read about
1917 and you read about certain things
but do you think in a modern age a thing
like that could never happen well it
comes back it is genius it comes back
and it's too bad but I think the people
working on this have been incredible at
the job they've done it's really been
incredible but there's tremendous
amounts of not only masks of ventilators
and respirators and everything you can
think of it's all being much of it and
almost I could say all of it is made
manufactured right now Steve place there
were questions about you
this malaria droid have those questions
in Alphen Rizal well I don't know that
resolved I could say that it's going to
be distributed I know New York is
getting I think 10,000 units and
numerous other people it's really it
could be the malaria drug plus the Z
Peck but and we're gonna find out we're
gonna find out I I feel look I feel as
the expression goes what do we have to
lose because you know I feel very I feel
very good about it
Tony would feel you know like he'd like
samples done in a certain way and I
understand that to what many doctors
agree with that we'd have much time
you know we have a lot of very sick
people right down in hospitals all over
the place and speaking with the governor
New York Cuomo I said how's it look he's
got a lot of sick people so we're going
to be delivering and a lot of samples to
New York and other places and we're
gonna find out very shortly whether or
not it's gonna work I feel very
confident I mean I've seen things that
surprised me frankly there are as Tony
said there are other things we're
looking at to vaccine of course is
incredible but this is more immediate
right now this to me would be the
greatest thing that could happen this
would be a gift from heaven this would
be a gift from God if it works so we're
going to pray to God that it does work
it would be a fantastic thing
during your businesses especially your
hotels my businesses yeah is that true
and Keith would you say is thriving when
you decide to close down your hotels and
your businesses no I would say but you
know I'm very under levered and
everything so that's good but is it
hurting my yeah it's hurting me and it's
hurting Hilton and it's hurting all of
the great hotel chains all over the
world it's hurting everybody I mean
they're very few business that are doing
well now there are some that are like as
an example the Walmarts of the world
because everybody's lined up to get
things and stock up their house and this
and that but sure it hurts my business
but did you or anyone in your
administration talk to anyone at the
Trump Organization about the potential
effects of the coronavirus no I didn't
speak to anybody I speak to my sons but
I talk about the Carnival us but not as
not as it pertains to my business they
basically follow the rules when they say
close them down in New York we close
them down or wherever they may be have I
actually have them all over the world
and when they say close them down we
close them down what Kelly we'll have
nothing planned at mar-a-lago but right
now I think mar-a-lago I guess I haven't
even asked but I imagine that's closed
down just like a lot of other businesses
in Florida do you expect your family
companies to seek government assistance
I don't know I mean I just don't know
what the government assistance would be
for what I have I have hotels
everybody knew I had hotels when I got
elected they knew I was a successful
person when I got elected so it's one of
those things I guess I get paid four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year I give it up I put it back into the
nation I usually I have to by the way
you have to designate where you want it
so I oftentimes give it to opioid you
know research and things but but as far
as the the hotels and everything I mean
I have to do what everyone else is doing
I I would probably decide to close
things up I think it's a good thing they
show you don't want people getting
together and hotels and clubs and
everything you get together we want to
beat this deal so I have many
them hotels clubs things like that where
people get together I would think it
would be a good practice to close about
temperature test as we know we all came
into this room and Daniel I do it I do
it I have temperature tests and I I
don't I didn't ask everybody here but I
wouldn't be surprised if they had
temperature tests oh I think they are
pretty much the easiest thing is the
temperature I think they are I don't
know
are you learning a lot from the
temperature test Tony could you maybe
discuss that for a second I mean they
have a place they're not infallible I
mean there's so many ways to get around
that I mean I mean right now every time
I certainly here we get every time I go
into a different room I got my
temperature taken but we see that on the
outside that some people like this very
low there is a role for it under certain
circumstances what I don't see is a
massive distribution of thermometers
that are gonna actually have a major
impact on what I showed what we need to
do right I've seen things
when Tony mentions thermometers and they
aim something at your far head they stay
this far away boom and they tell you
what your temperatures I said I've never
seen that people I've learned a lot I've
learned a lot it's incredible go ahead
suggesting that usually taking action on
the virus in January and February doctor
foul cheese indicated that your action
in the Chinese travel ban helped America
immensely what do you say to the
Washington Post well I love whoever
you're with that's because I think
that's such a nice that's such a nice
question no I think the Washington Post
covers us very inaccurately covers me
very inaccurately I saw this story I
think it's a disgrace
but it's the Washington Post and I guess
we have to live with it
it's a very it's a very inaccurate quiet
quiet it's a very inaccurate story from
many people I get a lot of credit for
having closed our country very early to
a very heavily infected country China
unfortunately China I wish I wish China
would have told us more about what was
going on in China long prior to us
reading about it even though the news
isn't exactly disseminated as you know
China kicked the Washington Post out of
China and they kicked the New York Times
out of China and I guess the Wall Street
Journal that's okay I mean that's what
they do and I think it's a terrible
thing they did but I also think it's
terrible when people write in accurately
about you and they write in accurately
about me every single day every single
hour and by the way your group really I
really think and I just say fair not
good or bad I think you write very
fairly and do very fair reports about
the great job that all of us are doing
that this group behind me is doing it's
so insulting when they write phony
stories that they know are fake news
because they're not insulting me they're
insulting everybody these incredible
people that have worked so hard so long
that are thinking about nothing other
than this invisible enemy they have done
such an incredible job and they will
continue and we're gonna win and
there'll be a lot of celebration when we
went and we're gonna win with as few
lives lost as possible that's the game
win with as few lives lost as possible
it's a tough enemy it's a tough killer
far bigger far more vicious than ever
before but I appreciate you saying it
because the fact that we closed so early
to China and most people Hey look I was
called
xenophobic by sleepy Joe Biden I was
called a racist by Democrats a racist I
was a racist because I decided that I
didn't want to have people that could
hurt our country come in and I was
pretty much in a very small group of
people I will tell you it was a tiny
little group most people even that
worked in the White House disagreed with
me very strongly saving of those many
weeks was a tremendous tremendous thing
and when they keep talking about acting
early that was the ultimate act that was
the biggest act because we didn't and
then I'll also closed Europe early very
early and I took a lot of heat for that
too but that was a good thing now
they're doing similar things that way so
I didn't act late I acted early
I acted far before anybody thought I
should be I took tremendous criticism
from the various papers from many of the
papers so I very much appreciate the
question it might have been it might
have been more of a statement than a
question but whatever it may have been I
appreciate it very much
kind of done these different measures
we've seen California order one in New
York you know just be similar do you
want all the states to do one uniform no
no they they can do what they want to do
if California can get a mask sooner than
we can get it for them through all of
the things we're able to do but we're
going to end up with a big oversupply at
some point you know at some point this
is going away and we're going to end up
with a big oversupply and you know what
in this case that's going to be ok
but if California if Gavin can go out
and order gowns faster or masks good
masks faster or other things faster
that's good we do have a lot of I mean
the coordination with the ships that
we're sending in as you know the the
medical ships that we're sending in and
even cruise liners we're going to be
sending in probably cruise liners into
some areas in particular California and
in particular New York but if somebody
can do something faster if they can
order that mask faster than us I want
them to be a better
so people can't leave their homes that
you know certain businesses recorded a
very much with them you don't want all
those defeatist thing I just don't have
to be at this moment because we have
places in the country where you know
states where they have two people or
three people and those people are in
quarantine and you can't put on them
what you're putting in New York well you
do have a tremendous problem I mean we
have large portions of the country
middle America where you know they have
a few people so it may be a time I hope
that never happens where we need to take
very drastic action but right now that's
not in the same ballpark
yeah go ahead please we're day six in
your 15 days of recommendations a lot of
people are following them some people
are not do you think the American people
are doing enough right now to slow I
think and some people are not but I
think they are I think it's going to
have a very profound effect I mean we'll
know a little bit more on day 14 and 15
we'll see once we get what we're going
to see we have to see what the result is
we want to flatten that out and we're
going to see what the result is I just
want to say I'm going to negotiate a
very large transaction and I've been
negotiating it for two days so I'm gonna
take one or two more questions and then
I'm gonna leave it to vice president
pence the various elements of the
package Steve go ahead number of groups
are calling for the postponement or
cancellation of the Olympics have you
given even flirt no I haven't I look we
understand the difficulty of that and
he's a very good friend of mine you you
talk all of you take a look at Shinzo
Abbey he's a he's a great gentleman he
loves this country we have an incredible
relationship we just finished a trade
deal with a 40 billion dollar trade deal
with Japan and Prime Minister Robbie as
a big decision to make
you know they they have built one of the
most beautiful venues I've ever seen
they're all ready to go it's not late
it's not over budget it's not it was
just done flawlessly and it's beautiful
and they're sitting back and saying you
know I I have I told him I said that's
your decision and it is his decision and
I know he's going to make it soon I
don't know what it's gonna be and I
didn't think I should be influencing it
at all I mean the job that Japan has
done on that venue
is incredible so I mean there are
options obviously including delay and
maybe delay for next year but that's
totally up to them we'll see what they
do when did you first learn that this
was gonna be a problem well you know
when I learned I started doing the
closing so you know probably around that
time we didn't learn much I think you're
gonna ask a little bit about China
responsibility I do think that again I
have great respect for China
I like China I I think the people of
China are incredible I have a tremendous
relationship with President Xi I wish
they could have told us earlier about
what was going on and said we didn't
know about it until it started coming
out publicly but I wish they could have
told us earlier about because we could
have come up with a solution
Tony foul Qi and all of the people the
talent that we have would have loved to
have had three or four months of
additional time if you knew if this was
going to be happening they didn't have
that time they read about it in
newspapers like everybody else the China
was very secretive okay very very
secretive and that's unfortunate with
that I have great respect for that
country I have great respect for the
leader of that country and like it he's
a friend of mine but I wish they were
able to I wish they would have told us
earlier Steve that they were having a
problem because they were having a big
problem and they knew it and I wish they
could have given us an advanced warning
because we could have done we could have
had a lot of things as an example some
of the things that we're talking about
will we order them as quickly as we can
if we had a two or three month
difference in time it would have been
much better yeah because China was
extremely secretive about the
several of your advisors have been
warning have been critical of China
secretary Pompey was talking about it
yesterday and he had been saying so for
quite some time so why then on January
24th did you tweet that China has been
working very hard to contain the
coronavirus that the United States
greatly appreciates their efforts and
transparency because China has worked
very hard
China's lost thousands and thousands of
paper right now they weren't transparent
they were transparent at that time but
when we saw what happened they could
have been transparent much earlier than
they were after try China just so you
understand China's not a beneficiary
here China has lost thousands and
thousands of people China has gone
through hell over this they've gone
through hell and I've had conversations
with President Xi I just wish they could
have told us earlier they knew they had
a problem earlier I wish they could have
said that number of available tests on
number of inflated from the federal
stockpile well I'm gonna leave that up
to doctor foul Qi and everybody else and
I think the answer is we want to share
them I would imagine we want to share
the numbers as well do you want to
discuss their billion masks that you
cited they're due for delivery delivery
it has been 18 months the last number of
ventilators we have is 12 to 13,000 and
give us an updated number well there's
numbers like this you know a ventilator
is a machine it's a very complex machine
and to think that we have to order
hundreds of thousands nobody's ever
heard of a thing like this you know when
we had in the stockpile we had thousands
in a stockpile thousands ready to go
that's a lot all of a sudden you need
hundreds of thousands and you're not
talking about you know the mask is
whether it's plastic or whether it's
material that's one thing but you're
talking about a very sophisticated
computerized machine and delicate and
you need hundreds of thousands of them
nobody's ever heard of a thing like that
with that being said General Motors Ford
so many companies I had three calls
yesterday directly without having to
institute like you will do this
these companies are making them right
now but to think of these numbers it's
it's pretty yeah you bet well we've
spoken a lot about mass this morning but
the president's also given the task
force a priority of assessing the
availability and expanding the
availability of ventilators and on
Monday we will detail some very
encouraging news for Americans you speak
about the number of 13,000 it is a
little more than that that we have in
the national stockpile but it's
important to remember that that doesn't
include the more than a hundred thousand
ventilators that are in health care
facilities and hospitals around America
today
it doesn't include what will be produced
as the president said we're seeing
companies step forward well these
manufacturers tell us that a ventilator
actually isn't a very complicated piece
of equipment and many of them are
literally surging forward to create more
ventilators but one of the more exciting
developments in the last week which will
detail more on Monday is that in in the
president's engagement with our health
care community we learned that that
ventilators that are currently used by
anesthesiologists that are used in
outpatient clinics and in other
procedures can be converted to be used
as ventilators for people struggling
with the effects of the corona virus
we've confirmed that a particular screen
in that device can be changed readily
we're working with the FDA to approve
that but again this is a it's a great
testament of the American people and our
health care professionals that are
stepping forward and and bringing ideas
forward that that literally as well
document Monday will increase the supply
of ventilators by tens of thousands but
look the president's made it clear we
want to make sure that all the
incredible courageous men
women who are serving in health care
around America have the support they
need that our patients that are
struggling with recovering from
coronavirus I have the equipment they
need and we'll have we'll have a lot of
detail on Monday as we continue to
assess today do we have that can you
give us the number that we have let me
let I'll speak to them so I'm gonna
answer your question and then try to try
to persuade you to stop asking about a
specific number okay so from March 2nd
to March 14th we have put over 10
million laboratory tests into the u.s.
commercial market and we expect that by
March 28th to be well over 27 million
into the market so that answers your
question let me tell you why it's not
the right question not every lab can run
every test not every test is completely
self-contained so the more important
question is not how many tests are in
the market we got them in the market but
is to make sure that every segment of
the market
has the kind of test that they can use
the things you've promised are happening
yes they are happy they are apps we
promised 1 or 4 million there's 10
million tests in the market now the
masks that are in the strategic reserve
being deployed mr. vice president
yes the masks in the strategic national
stockpile 13,000 anymore it would be a
lower number would that be fair to say
masks layers he I'm sorry the
thank you we're trying to understand if
the things we have been told sitting
through these briefings for many days
are happening and getting into the hands
of the healthcare providers you
understand you understand it here to
tell that woman Kelly you understand
exactly what he's saying
and what are you saying is rather
incredible because we we inherited an
obsolete broken system and when you hear
the number of tests that we'll be
providing and are now it's incredible
and I've heard a lot of governors say
the same thing we took over an obsolete
broken testing system that wouldn't have
worked for even a small problem let
alone one of the biggest pandemics in
history and what these gentlemen have
done is incredible I am going now to
negotiate a great deal for our workers
and our citizens I'll be back tomorrow
we're probably doing this tomorrow and
if I might I'd like to ask vice
president pence to take over and thank
you all very much military has some
planes to converis morocco and through
to pick up Americans to bring them home
and stranded there but there's still a
lot of other Americans who are stranded
and can't get home so does the military
plan to send planes quick those folks up
what will those planes be going when
will they be going and can you're sure
Americans those who are stranded in port
covers that they will be able to get
home well we we received a briefing this
morning from the State Department about
their efforts and we want to be very
clear while the president has suspended
all travel from Europe including the UK
and Ireland suspended all travel course
from China since January that any
American who can get home can come home
they'll go through additional screening
that's all been implemented and and is
working in an orderly way at a number of
airports around the country but there
are instances Morocco being among them
where there simply are not flights to
get home our State Department has been
working very closely with our embassies
in those relevant countries
I was told this morning that go all the
way going back to bringing Americans
back from China that we have made
individual efforts to bring home about
3,000 Americans I think there is an
ongoing effort to address that with
chartered commercial flights that the
government is providing obviously also
military transport is available but our
task force received a briefing this
morning and we would just encourage any
American that's looking on from overseas
contact the local US Embassy let them
know about your circumstances and and
know that we're gonna work continue to
work very diligently to get to get our
Americans home you guys have announced
that standardized testing is essentially
canceled in this country to the tens of
millions of students out there the
teachers and their parents who sort of
scratching their head wondering what
does that mean obviously a lot of this
is driven by local school districts by
the state is there any federal guidance
on this and if not today could you have
secretary DeVos or somebody come and
explain that to the millions who are
sitting literally sitting at home trying
to figure out what exactly that means
well I think it's a terrific question
and we will bring secretary Betsy DeVos
here tomorrow or on Monday to address
our efforts the the objective here was
as as people are embracing the
president's 15 days to slow the spread
we have decisions by local school boards
and local and state officials that have
canceled school or suspended school for
a time and we wanted the federal
Department of Education to make it clear
that the burden of standardizing testing
which back in my days as governor I
remember takes a number of days and
sometimes up to a week to administer is
not going to be placed on schools but
we'll have the secretary here to address
that very specifically and it's a very
good point on your part
as a medication question and I wanted to
ask it while the president was here
because earlier he tweeted that there
were two they just wanted to certain
medications that when taken together
quote have a real chance to be one of
the biggest game changes in the history
of medicine and that they should be
quote put in use immediately since he's
not here I can't ask him what he meant
but I'm wondering if dr. fats you the
animal could clarify it you have any
sense of what he was talking about and
whether his seventy four and a half
million Twitter followers should be
taking medical advice from him or from
someone else the president brought
together the top pharmaceutical
companies in America and in the world a
number of weeks ago and they formed a
consortium to work on a range of
responses
beginning with therapeutics which for a
layman like me that just means medicine
to make you feel better they're already
going to work on that we actually think
dr. Fauci I think there's some sense
that that our great pharmaceutical
companies may actually be producing
therapeutics that will give relief to
Americans struggling with coronavirus as
soon as this spring we also challenge
them to work together as rapidly as
possible to develop a vaccine going
forward and as dr. Fauci has indicated
we we brought a vaccine to clinical
trials now the better part of a week ago
the fastest time in history now it's the
first phase of the trials and people
should understand as our health experts
have described that it there'll be
there'll be a period of as much as a
year and a half before we can make those
vaccines available but as the president
said at this podium there is some
anecdotal evidence that that several
existing medicines may have brought
relief to patients struggling in China
and and in Europe and the president has
tasked the FDA to work
very rapidly to allow what's called
off-label use for those one is a malaria
medicine but this morning I think the
President reiterated the the hopefulness
that he feels about this that that
because these are medications that our
time honors and tested they've been
taken for many many years that we want
to pursue number one making those
available if someone's doctor believes
that it's appropriate and the doctor
would be able to prescribe that medicine
even though that's not indicated that's
called an off-label use but the other
piece is as dr. Fauci said and I'll
yield to him in deploying those those
medicines we're working specifically
with one state to do so in a way that
represents a clinical trial so it's not
would not just be compassionate use
which the medicines are already being
used for in some jurisdictions today but
also it we could study it and determine
the viability of it and in fact we're
working we're working diligently right
now with that supply chain to make sure
that those medicines are available
doctor found changes you want to speak
to that really you know it's it's
essentially what I what I said multiple
times from this podium is that when you
have first of all we're trying to
develop de novo drugs that are not yet
out there not that not approved that
ultimately would be effective and the
way you prove that is to do a randomized
control trial to prove safety and
efficacy I'm not totally sure what the
president was referring to but I believe
is referring to a report that used both
hydroxychloroquine and is it from arson
together to have some possibility of
being in effect many of the things that
you hear out there are what I had called
anecdotal reports they may be true but
they're anecdotal so the only thing that
I was saying is that if you really want
to definitively know if something works
that you've got to do the kind of trial
that you get the good information the
president is talking about hope for
people and it's not an unreasonable
thing to hope for people so when you
have a proof
drugs that physicians have the option in
a decision between the physician and the
patient
are you gonna use a drug that someone
says from an anecdotal standpoint not
completely proven but might have some
effect there are those who lean to the
point of giving hope and saying give
that person the option of having access
to that drug and then you have the other
group which is my job as a scientist to
say my job is to ultimately prove
without a doubt that a drug is not only
safe but that it actually works those
two things are really not incompatible
when you think about that particularly
when you're in an arena where you don't
have anything that's proven we went
through the same sort of thing with a
little bit of a different twist during
the hiv/aids epidemic until we finally
develop drugs that were absolutely
knockout drugs that were safe and that
were effective but in the beginning
there was that tension about that so you
really got to have a balance I've got to
do my job as a scientist and all this
have other things to do great let me
just say I hope this morning has been
informative we will be back again
tomorrow and I hope the American people
are encouraged because of the incredible
whole-of-government approach because of
our collaboration with States you're
seeing testing expanded all across the
country that incredible public-private
partnership with commercial labs is now
making testing available that by the
tens of thousands we're working very
diligently with incredible response from
American industry to make sure that
personal protective equipment and
ventilators and all the things that our
health care providers need to meet this
moment is there but let me just say
again what every American can do today
and that is first and foremost heed your
state and local authorities there are
individual states California and
Washington state and at this moment
especially New York that have issued
guidance to their citizens and as the
president said we wholly support the
leadership that those governors are
providing
in their states but secondly every
single American can put into practice
the principles of our 15 days to slow
the spread the president's coronavirus
guidelines as I said we're six days in
and the purpose of these is is not
because every American is at risk of
serious illness as we said before of all
our experts tell us all the data shows
that the risk of serious illness to the
average American remains low but because
the coronavirus is we think three times
more contagious than the flu to slow the
spread to literally lower that curve and
and spare Americans around our country
with being exposed to or contracting the
coronavirus or worse every single one of
us can put these principles into
practice I recommend that you go to
coronavirus gov a sit your family down
call a neighbor and a friend support
efforts in your local community to put
these principles into practice and as
people all across this country continue
to do just that I just know we'll get
through this and we'll get through this
together
thank you all all right the president
the vice president and his team wrapping
up about an hour and a half long news
conference at time contentious the vice
president saying this is a whole of
America approach and we are in six days
of 15 days to slow